j'avais une question pour toi parce que
tu dit que effectivement emmanuel macron
à des très belles idées je sais pas si
les a mis en place durant les cinq ans
qui sont passées mais pour toi c'est
quoi les très belles idées des manuels
macro du coup tu as quelques grandes
lignes un peu oui mais je vais donner un
objet d un exemple très concret il fait
revenir dessus c'est celui qui me parle
plus en tant qu'étudiant je suis pas
encore d'en calculer les impôts tout ça
donc pas du tout - tant qu'étudiant
comme je disais j'ai perdu mon job
étudiant avec l'aco de l'année dernière
à cause de la coved j'étais très heureux
d'avoir des repas à 1 euro aux le midi
et le soir ça veut dire qu'en une
semaine du lundi au vendredi je payais
10 euros pour mehr pas d'accord je suis
désolé c'est une mesure que moi en tant
qu'étudiant qui m'a plu alors certes il
n'a pas tout bien fait encore une fois
je l'entends mais je trouve qu'il a fait
un certain nombre de choses notamment
pour moi mon échelle que je trouve tout
à fait respectable tout à fait alors
justement parce que les le repas un euro
on a déjà parlé mais ce qui a quelque
chose d'autre parce que dans tout ce
programme n'y a pas que l'europe à 1
euro je veux dire s il ya quelque chose
d'autre un peu qu'il a plus ou pas on
avait des jeunes justement il ya une
surtout un truc qui me plaît pas du tout
chez marine le pen et c'est pour ça que
je dis que second tour j'ai voté
emmanuel macron j'ai eu l'opportunité
d'échanger avec julien odoul et de
débattre à ce niveau là je trouve qu'ils
ont une vision notamment sur la société
et sur la place de certaines personnes
notamment ceux qui portent le pain les
femmes qui portent le voile qui est tout
à fait
abject à mon goût et donc du coup je
trouve que marine le pen ne représente
pas les valeurs que j'aimerais pour la
france à ce qu'on reparle toujours au
delà de la religion moi j'ai repris
parce que géraldine hier tu m'as tu m'as
demandé vraiment son programme alors tu
veux juste dire trois points que je
trouvais super intéressant pour ceux qui
portent le voile pour ceux qui lui sont
reprochés et ça c'est très intéressant
toi tu lui diras tu m'as l'air à trois
points noirs que tu as chanté
et parlé tu parlais du repas à 1 euro
après tu sais qui est aussi il ya aussi
des jeunes qui sont entrepreneurs donc
en fait entrepreneur c'est mon cas j'ai
hâte et entrepreneurs pas d'impôt sur le
revenu pas d'impôt sur les sociétés pour
tous les jeunes de moins de 30 ans mois
ci si j'avais pu économiser tous les
impôts que j'ai payé là j'ai 30 ans ça
m'aurait fait très plaisir alors il ya
ça sans suite mener leur énergie fallait
pas finançable ça leur a donné juste si
elle c'est la marque et ce avant son
programme c'est quelle est la stratégie
à
chaque fois vous dit marine le pen ce
n'est pas possible parce qu'il ya ces
histoires voilà maintenant j'aimerais
juste encore les autres points l'énergie
à 5,5 ouais ouais ouais
non mais attendez juste une tva à zéro
sur tout ce qui est des produits
premiers pâtes le riz et le blé qui gêne
c'est qu'on arrête on m'a dit m y'aura
marine le pen y aura le chaos mais ce
que ça peut être meilleur qu'aujourd'hui
puisque la série manga nicolas non mais
ce qu'elle dit et qui perd intéressant
je vais vous dire ce n'est pas parce que
tu veux la paix chine et ses missions
mais non mon intérêt c'est une mission
politique n'intéresse personne vous
connaissez l'audience mieux qu'eux
n'avaient aucune émission politique qui
marche en france et aujourd'hui il
faudrait des émissions pédagogiques pour
que les gens ne s'arrêtent pas juste au
dessus ou en dix ans elle est
sympathique elle aime les chats ont la
dédiabolisation c'est ça mais 40 qu'on
rentre dans le fond et face à baba
encore le [ __ ] face à ma barre
[Rires]
mais
aujourd'hui je voulais aller fêter la
fin du ramadan je vous entends un
service vous souvenez de vos scores je
suppose d'hier - elle fait 30% sur les
18 24 et 28 % sur les 25 35 donc à un
moment donné il va bien falloir
s'adresser à ces gens pour qu'ils
comprennent ce qu'est le programme de
marine le pen et qu'il est intenable
parce que les fausses promesses
effectivement peut-être comme avec moins
de tv heroes paradise moi aussi j'en ai
bien sûr que tout à fait fausses dents
avait fait défaut sauf qu'il ya un
moment donné où le programme jeunes et
tiendrait n'est pas un sournois comique
et non plus répondre at c'est à dire
quand on revient on revient en arrière
vers les normes et la brèche s'ouvrait
sur koné on est sur des titres dirigent
et j alors moi les propos je comprends
qu'ils aient une polémique non pas parce
que tu as dit que tu allais voter pour
marine le pen mais parce qu'en fait
c'est un tsunami tu es une ancienne miss
france qui est une chroniqueuse dans une
émission très populaire ça
qu'aujourd'hui comme l'a dit très
justement gilles à part en gros les
artistes qui disons votre mari jean luc
mélenchon et ça passe ou les sportifs
dix 10 ans votent pour macro et ça passe
et pourquoi ça passe mieux non mais
parce qu'on fait c'est nouveau dans la
sphère médiatique aujourd'hui les gens
connus ne se sont jamais positionnée
pour marine le pen oh non mais on a bon
témoin jeudi à régler avec la gelée le
rendu vers les play boys band et j'ai lu
des choses qui mais qui convient de
noter le groupe absolument parole jeudi
juste au contraire que tu as eu le
courage de dire à la télévision devant
toujours ben moi je voterais pour marine
le pen ça c'est la première chose donc
je comprends la polémique et l'effet de
surprise parce que ça leur est une
franchise également je je je compte je
considère que quand moi par exemple dit
que je suis une donneuse de leçons parce
que en gros je suis censé être pro
macron alors que macro à et c'est tout
non je sais que vous êtes provoqueront
vous êtes une dose de doullens mais non
mais parce que moi par exemple mais là
on parlait de match en témoigne le
premier parti de france aujourd'hui un
nom mais vous êtes plutôt l'extrême
droite avec marine le pen mais d'autres
aussi carrier en politique
juste ok c'est l'expression maman maman
fait ce que moi si je te pour un
candidat je veux pas que ce soit avec
pato sur delphi ou mon frère mon père
mon frère la maman effectivement ça une
petite connotation dans l'est dans les
régimes autoritaires c'est le petit peu
le petit père des peuples c'était pas
saïd sadi et donc forcément c'est un des
plus grands dictateurs du monde le vin
l'union de leur salaire mais jamais
jamais sauf que il y en a qui écoute ça
et là mais elle peut ne pas meilleur
mais aussi le sentiment fort
jeudi marc d'orange une parole de l'ami
la personne à leurs partenaires alors
marc mentel justement sérieux rassemble
et qui aime vraiment les gens et j'en ai
marre là depuis un an on stigmatise les
gilets jaunes on se dit que matisse les
gens qui veulent pas se faire vacciner
et on stigmatise les gens qui ne veulent
plus de leur contrat et sylvain joyal et
matiz elle aussi je mange donc je suis
moi ce que je suis c'est sûr montrent l
amour une partie de banales comptines à
gauche a applaudi des
choses déclaré m alors en fait c'est
comme dans une relation amoureuse mais
pendant cinq ans cécilia des
amoureuses parce que c'est quand même
important ces gammes encore voilà il ya
des mises au point ça fonctionne pas il
ya des mises au point mais après il ya
une cassure il ya une cassure il ya je
vais vous emmerdez il ya macron dégagé à
les lire et je n'ai et au bout d'un
moment voilà fond quand là quand la
relation amoureuse ne fonctionne plus au
bout de cinq ans on dit bon on reste bon
moi me et puis on a autre chose à tout
ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit j'aimerais
essayer autre chose c'est vrai que si
avec mac par exemple et met encore s'ils
avaient eu mélenchon en face de macron
torre voter mélenchon mélenchon est donc
si c'est pas très important en fait mais
non mais non c'est vrai on lui a fait la
g mais il ya des points dans le
programme que j'aime beaucoup il ya des
points que j'aime pas comme le programme
par exemple de mélenchon moi mon
problème c'est humainement je trouve
qu'il a été méprisant pendant tout le
quinquennat et qu'il est qu il est
hautain
je pense que c'est comme ça il ya
beaucoup de français qui pensent ça
alors pourquoi stigmatiser
quelqu'un qui veut essayer de changer de
relation parce que cette relation
amoureuse avec les français est fausse
sonne faux et ça ne fonctionne pas alors
tu fais de vous redonner la forme
[Applaudissements]
ces accords nous a donné la parole qu'on
le dit personne parmi ses ébats si ces
personnes eh ben c'est pas moi
non mais le côté mais je donnais
le côté mer mère bienveillante mère
nourricière femme qu'elle sort c'est
moins bien mais je lâche que je veux
dire c'est la berge pour lord a fait un
super tour g sociétal regarde prises de
position sur les vg regarde son
programme sur éventuellement
non mais en fait
elle n'est pas d'accord avec la merci
non non vous la forcez un programme
parfait encore une fois personne
appartient pas de maman les congés on a
dit cela mais elle vient de la france du
haut contrairement à mâcon accueillir de
la france du bas et qui est arrivée par
la mairie collange il veut vous défoncer
et
vous recommencez avec toi un aspect la
fesci j'ai pour vous faire masser
donneuse de leçons non mais mais
n'aurait pas donné de l'avion elles
émanaient de chine alors je l'avais pas
dit mais si vous l'êtes
pour la sambre de votre carrière
non pas pour moi si vous faites une
erreur terrible et vous recommencez
quand delphine dit maman votre premier
mot c'est maman c'est ce qu'on utilise
dans les dictatures c'est à dire que et
ben non vous refusez vous lui refuser
joli collectif pour marine le pen il a
le droit je
l'adoré j'ai adoré la réaction que j'ai
le plus aimé ici c'est la réaction de
bilel je suis désolé bilel et il y des
il est à fond emmanuel macron mais il a
respecté non seulement on a dit non non
non et non il a respecté ce qu'est la
scala di des fines mais il n'y a pas
essayé de lui donner des leçons c'est ce
que j'ai aimé voilà pile est non mais
c'est vrai quand tu les essais
importants et je coche je le vois quand
je parle avec eux avec mes amis et mes
potes et je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus constructif c'est carrément si je
vais leur dire non au vote pas ma faim
vote pas marine le pen vote mâcon c'est
comme ça si marine le pen c'est
l'extrême droite et on dire ouais mais à
part ça il veut dire ouais mais macron
c'est un banquier ou 8 me sur des trucs
comme ça et en fait le fait d'avoir un
débat d'idées de dire mao khê certes
marine le pen à la télémesure qui est
pas mal c'est là où on sait devient
intéressant et il ya du vrai débat et
quand on commence à s insurger les idées
et voir qu'en fait bas marine le pen
elle n'était pas bien là dessus macron
il ne fait pas bien là dessus et c'est
là où on avance à allons donner au privé
on affine et on affine on a fini c'est
ça c'est ce qu'ils disent à ce qu'on n'a
pas la vie des gens moi je comprends et
hier la polémique qui a eu parce que
elle a pu choquer certaines personnes
parce que c'est comme on dit elle est
sûre comme a dit jardiner sur un talk
elle est allée dans sa carrière souvent
les gens et qu'ils votent le pen maison
plus de carrière on les voit plus c'est
fini et des antilles il n'existe plus
dit je vote le pen mais ans mais je
m'étais fait donc suite non mais attends
tu sais ce que je t'ai dit en loge six
mois ça s'arrêtait à cause de ça je
pense que nationalement il faudrait
peut-être comprendre qu'il ya un
problème dans notre pays c'est ce que
c'est at a eu une hémorragie hier de le
dire ce que les gens ne veulent pas dire
parce qu'ils savent qu'ils peuvent
perdre ni parfums peuvent perdre en
disant cela
je comprends la polémique des gens que
tu as pu choquer mais j'ai regardé et je
le dis j'ai regardé les commentaires
dans les commentaires faux c'est pareil
il faut pas mettre sous le tapis comme
on ne sait quoi lui à l'expression
papier la poussière la poussière la
poussière sous le tapis il faut pas
s'appeler se
situe peuvent être une balade je veux
mettre des fruits
chez moi je me suis dit que j'avais fait
un truc ça parce qu'il y en ait
commentaires si vous regardez bien elle
se fait pas tant insultes etc ça c'est
certain que lorsqu'il récite du souffle
tout ce qui tombe à dix mille à tous
ceux qui dix ans et bilel ces vidéos
mobile free mobile
devrait photo ap les reconnaît
m
[Applaudissements]
en fait ce qu'il a dit c'est très
intéressant quand il dit moi les gens je
leur dis pas voter macron parce que à
force de dire aux gens les parisiens les
journalistes la tribune que j'ai vu sur
les sportifs assez conquis son blindé
déjà à l'âge de 18 ans qu'on fait des
centres de formation qu'on les trompe
jamais venu explique ludovic cim-10
demain faut voter comme s'il faut voter
comme ça j'étais pas moi n'a pas mes
problèmes et papa pas su s'y est pas
trompé et a dit s'attendre en faire des
privilèges ne vient pas donner des
leçons aux français aujourd'hui les gens
vient de donner des leçons aux français
depuis paris depuis leurs bureaux depuis
lors leur truc de journalistes depuis la
rédaction
si ces charniers de raison qu'elle est
pour interroger le genre oui mais il
faut arrêter de me dire autrement dit
c'est pas la question la question
pour rien à me faire du bien
vraiment radio n'est pas dans mon corps
les narcisses est ce important je vais
pousser c'est important d'écouter qu'il
ya des gens qui galèrent depuis des
années pas d'aujourd'hui et
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont essayé la gauche
le centre la droite ça n'a pas marché tu
va le répéter tous les jours les jours
parce qu'elle est encore au deuxième
tour
vous comprenez rien vous êtes là tout le
temps à dire tu vois que l'open à sa foi
tu sa fracture au nez rien tu n'es du
coup bretigny que ça moi
je dis vous hissez les jours attention
attention je dis que c'est souvent à des
sondés ça je te le dis non mon réveil je
te le dis c'est toujours la même musique
2002 2006 est de l'aider à albas au
bauchi le pot très haut je pensais
prendre forme a lancé je dois descendre
alors attendez vous en ce moment j'ai un
problème avec vous
j'ai un problème physique non je rigole
mais qui n'a pas parlé mois après je
voudrais aussi bernard montiel inquiète
quand même dire son mot à dire bernard
et puis il a pas trouvé l'amour moi je
trouve ça je trouve ça très courageux de
la part de delphine qu'elle va voter
pour marine le pen et série permettez
moi de vous sucer mais c'est très bien
tu es un ami mais si je ne suis pas là
pour ça j'ai replay c'est très bien que
vous laissiez des gens dire ça à une
heure de grande écoute puisqu'elle
représente plus rien une grande partie
de l'électorat en revanche qui est
gênant et je suis désolé c'est ça aussi
la polémique ce sont les arguments dire
marine le pen je vais voter pour elle
parce que c'est une gentille maman elle
a des petits chatons tout mignon c'est
pas alors du moustique jalal mène depuis
des années une opération de
dédiabolisation et on allègue au second
plan le fait que c'est un parti qui lui
est clivant qui lui a des opinions qui
sont problématiques notamment sur les
femmes voilées et on met au premier plan
c'est une gentille femme qui a des
créations à son âme ajoute eric zemmour
parce qu'il a un labrador et quinet à
calais le couloir sur
j'aime sur qui peut renseigner chez que
nathalie arthaud à trois prochains
débats durent alors là oui on ne peut
pas dire ça non mais guillon que c'est
honteux alors oui versus et il peut dire
ce qu'il veut
moi je sais aussi
maire de pâtes
jour d'hui à
l'honneur de passer
on te parce que là vous êtes en train de
vouloir ridiculiser delphine c'est ça ça
vous là tu m'as donné tout ce que je
veux dire parce qu'il était sur le
dossier delphi il a vu que c'était pas
possible donc forcément ce mr je
comprends mieux maintenant faut des
classes elle dit elle parle avec son
coeur a dit quelque chose et là vous le
tenter vous tentez de dénaturer de
critiquer reste que d'ostraciser de
démonter ses arguments c'est dégueulasse
de faire ça c'est comme si elle avait
fait une faute en parlant de maman marie
bleus mais elle a déjà six et du mois
qui ont bougé libye non mais vous êtes
qu'iggy
chroniqueurs
comme il est 6 heures il peut dire
n'importe quoi une accord oui mais voilà
bah oui c'est la règle ici voilà bassil
fausse couche et moi je vais sus et
alors
je
mets toujours avec parcimonie
mais là vous attaquez la
cruche et
jugeant que book
je comprends parfaitement qu'elle donne
son avis qu'elle vote marine le pen ya
aucun problème après c'est devenu
compliqué aujourd'hui parce que dès lors
qu'on dit du bien de marine le pen et du
mal des manuels macro on est applaudie
et mais dès lors qu'on a le enfin dès
lors qu'on a envie de soutenir ou
emmanuel macron ou même de même à
soutenir manuel mac os ou d'être notre
marine le pen plus tôt on se fait
atomiser aime se lier donc c'est hyper
compliqué moi j'ai envie de dire à
delphine comme moi ce qui marche aux
pieds dans une eau glacée lambert six
semaines on a été applaudi tu as dit que
tu as reçu aucune erreur et que c'était
à ce que je représente les français les
provinces et les territoires et vous
leur 12 s en mode on le sait les paris
donc je suis réservé aux habitants la
campagne j'ai le droit d'être contre
marine le pen tepa de gerbe à toi ce que
tu es bien navire
[Rires]
ce qui me ce qui m'a choqué qui m'a
interpellé hier dans les propos delphine
sais pas quel vote marine le pen elle
fait ce qu'elle veut y a qu il ya un
français sur deux qui votent marine le
pen ya aucun problème moi ce qui m'a
dérangé c'est qu'elles disent que elle
veut que marine le pen devienne la maman
des français moi si tu peux pas couché
tous les ans dames et moi ce qui me pose
problème c'est que je n'ai pas envie que
marine le pen devienne la maman des
français en 2011 elle a été prise en
photo avec de néo-nazis je ne veux pas
que cette femme là deviennent la maman
d'être lancée en 2014 elle été prise en
photo avec le porte parole d'un
groupuscule anti migrants qui portait le
tatouage nazi je ne veux pas que cette
femme amal devient maman des français en
2019 en estonie elle a été prise en
photo avec un militant supprime assisté
elle a fait le geste suprémacistes je ne
veux pas que cette femme là tu deviennes
la maman des français voilà pourquoi les
propos de défilement choqué hier soir
oui en effet bon alors clément si tu
veux sortir comme ça des petits dos
peut-être sur toi on a des petits au
sein
pourquoi des règlements mais parce que
parce qu'il en a marre de fally d'accord
sans être menaçant directement mais je
suis pas menace mais si tu veux sentir
des dossiers seulement mais je tenais
vous fait mon procès ce soir et je ne
fais pas de pause en
six mois j'ai dit que tu me voulaient
voter marine le pen sans aucun problème
en a le droit de ne pas être là contre
m'est apparu pourquoi il n'est pas
directement alors juste parce que tu
étais enfin vous fait une fixette sur la
position de marine le pen au niveau du
voile alors il ya quand même juste en
mars 2018 emmanuel lacroix qu'hamdi le
voile nous insécurise parce qu'il est
contraire à la civilité dans notre pays
c'est à dire le rapport qu'il ya entre
les hommes et le temps surtout le serait
par ailleurs je jouais aujourd'hui
s'expliquer hier c'est que je suis
quelqu'un qui est dans l'intuition et
que aujourd'hui emmanuel macron nous
méprisent et hautain et moi je préfère
quelqu'un j'ai envie des séquelles sont
une réalité je suis déçu de ces cinq ans
et 11 mois essayer quelque chose d'autre
mais
aussi une source bien sûr ce que
guillaume a dit parce que voilà en fait
guillaume là ne m'a pas attaquer mois il
a il a attaqué une personne sur deux des
français et ce qui m'a choqué ce qui m'a
choqué c'est qu'il a dit cyril vous êtes
très courageux de pouvoir laisser parler
delphine à une heure de grande écoute et
dire des propos comme ça ses excuses à
choquer ceux qui me sucer
ce team shirts et qu'ils disent que j'ai
du courage
ce que vous avez du courage de m'avoir
laissé parler et d'avoir dit on peut
essayer quelque chose d'autre que macro
maintenant s'est banalisée ces
paroles-là
de vouloir essayer quelque chose d'autre
que macro on ne fait pas d'élections et
puis on le laisse à vie et n'ont jamais
reproché soit pas de problème mais si on
me propose un choix différent étant
donné que j'ai été déçu j'ai envie
d'essayer le choix différents points se
désole c'est que tout à l'heure par
exemple tu as dit que si ça avait été
mélenchon en face de mâcon tu aurais
voter mélenchon parce que vous savez pas
tout donner contre les normes m il ya
beaucoup de monde qui va voter contre
alors pas d'adhésion et ça ça me désole
on va passer cinq années horrible parce
que regarder myriam palumbo t il de plus
je pense la mort dans l'âme mais elles
votent contre macron a laissé ses
106 avait été non mesdames finale est
sur les dents dans tous les programmes
moi je parle de humainement j'ai le
droit de parler d' humainement c'est à
cause d'eux humainement ça cause de ce
principe de de sensations comme saïd et
de sentiments qui est des gens qui sont
allés dans la rue à occulter ce sens
attendait les mecs il ya un truc le
tournoi il a remué les nanas sans
rigoler et un toit qui vient de tomber
bon là c'est une grosse tuile est ce
qu'il fait pas de commenter merci il ya
une grosse grosse tuile qui vient de
tomber
[ __ ] merde bastia non franchement il
reste c'est un truc je vous dis on
dirait que j'apprends la nouvelle en
direct
françois hollande appelle à voter pour
emmanuel macron
à sept îles
[Applaudissements]
j
sakho fait autant que sur le coin de la
gueule j'attends quelqu'un met dix
meilleurs temps de merde c'est comme ça
je m'y attendais pas je dis cela car
elle attend d'elle en train de manger un
flot
de fou excuse moi mais là j'étais trop
d'émotions j'aimerais juste savoir si
voilà si guillaume ce soir tu dis bah
forcément je vote emmanuel macron
j'aimerais bien savoir si demain tu as
une émission pour dire est ce que vos
propos est-ce que les propos de
guillaume ont choqué est ce que
guillaume tu risques de perdre ton
travail est-ce que tu respires il vous
avez du courage de l'acier explique
s'exprimer comme ça sur une heure de
grande écoute comme si ce que je disais
c'était c'était c'était malsain c'était
une insulte